talking about L'Oreal Paris the fact
that you're part of a team of great
women Helen Mirren Jane Fonda the list
just goes on and not when you became
part of it what was that moment for you
I was so excited I was so excited when I
when I was approached by L'Oreal not
just because it's fun and it seemed like
a brain I could really get behind but
they really seemed like a brand that
stood for the same principles and ideas
that I myself aligned my energy and my
efforts to I you know they have had the
tech okay they've had the tagline
because you're worth it since I was born
before I was born and I thought that it
was very special I feel very honored and
proud to have aligned myself with a
brand that is so similar to my
principles they stand up for empowering
women it's about women it's about
finding your own worth in whatever way
that that happens I I loved that they
really were a brand that stood for
something then that I can get behind and
that's so great about you you actually
use your voice to make a difference you
actually speak up for other women who
can't have a voice and that's part of
what L'Oreal Paris is doing as well and
it's an interesting time in the industry
with everything that's happening how
important is this moment right now where
there's a shift in attitude for women it
is so exciting and thrilling and
encouraging and inspiring to see a real
groundswell of change change of opinion
change of mind that is what that will
serve as the basis as the impetus to
have and see and enjoy the fruits of
long-term change long-term change does
not come from a fad a movement can be a
fad if it's not founded in in a deeply
ingrained ubiquitous need and it in
order for it to be properly executed
carried and for us to reap the benefits
of it having effect you know wait for it
to affect us in a long-term sense
we have to continue to carry the message
we have to continue to go see films made
by women we have to continue to push our
daughters our sisters ourselves to get
behind the camera to pick up our pins to
pick up our cameras so start telling our
stories and participating in the
dialogue which is the expression of the
female experience and all of its varying
degrees the spectrum is vast and it has
been largely ignored and in chronically
underserved we are chronically
underrepresented in this industry we
make up over 51% of the viola the movie
ticket population over half the
population over half the the ticket
purchasing population yet 30% of
speaking roles or named roles we're done
by women and that is not even taking
into consideration the content of what
they were saying when you do it the
numbers get even even more depressing
not to mention the pay gap the deep
disparity between wages between men and
women doing the same jobs and and in the
lifespan that we have these are
institutions that have been needed to be
challenged overturned now is the time
where we're starting to realize the
damage done by these antiquated
institutions and outdated norms of
protecting the status quo that hurts
women and under serves women and
underrepresented on our laurels and and
ride the wave of which I'm very happy to
see post post all of the social
movements that we have seen recently
I've noticed my own life you know that
the effects of such a dramatic and
inspiring climate change in the cultural
conversation that the the collective
conversation that we're having regarding
this outdated system that needs to
really be overturned and I think it's
it's it's thrilling to see what these
conversations have become and
and to see some of the stories and the
policies changed so quickly in the wake
of these movements and when I compare it
to what I experienced two years ago it
is thrilling and inspiring now it's our
job I think as women to make sure it
lasts she's running for president next
year guys I you know I feel your energy
and this I just got chills listening to
what you're saying and the fact that
we're working together to do this and
making this change happen are you
finally seeing that we're starting to
get that respect for women in the
industry do you see that change slowly
happening I do I you know I used to get
10 to 15 scripts across my desk every
week and I would laugh I laugh errand or
cry depending on the day at if I could
find a script out of that 10 15 maybe I
found one two that had female characters
in them of course there are you know as
many actresses starting out in this
industry or fighting for these roles as
there are men were paid less but we're
represented and as I said 30% of the
roles and if you get one or two
characters in a script obviously it's it
makes the market for women especially
young women who's starting out this
gives the same for crew behind the
camera writers directors one person to
the directors of of the top 100 grossing
films two percent of the writers you
know 80 percent of the top grossing
films are produced directed or written
by men and it's so it's unsurprising
that when 15 scripts crossed my desk a
week I'm reading one or two female
characters that are just characters
meaning they're flawed or interesting
smart complex they've got some character
to them and now this week I had this
conversation a few minutes ago with my
agent and they said I've read in this in
this week I've read out of all the
scripts across my desk I've read 5 out
of 15 that had female characters that
really represented one of the varying
aspects on the spectrum the wide
spectrum of what it is that what the
female experience is and I'm very
inspired and proud to see that change
now it's our job to go and make them the
keep writing them to fight for them to
be seen to buy the tickets to support us
to support each other even in outside of
this industry we need to change the way
we talk about women on a social level on
a political level we need to we need to
not wait for 15 20 women to come forward
before we stop asking what's what's your
motive we really need to to realize that
if if justice and inequality is denied
to us one of us if it's denied to
everyone and I really I'm really
inspired I think I think this is this is
changing I'm seeing it right now just by
the number of scripts I can tell you
yeah if featured strong women and that
is no accident I want to see those
movies do well as well in the box office
so that the change lasts and it keeps
going so our daughters have a totally
different so our daughters have a
totally different relationship that
seeing their reflection as by way of of
this innit of the entertainment industry
and you're part of that movement and
it's so great that you are part of it
you're making that change happen and one
of the thing is your character that you
created Mira thank you who controls
water yeah I mean that role itself as
superheroes in general I have a way of
just giving girls and boys an
opportunity to feel confident there's
something that really resonates with
them yeah taking on this character do
you realize the impact you're gonna have
on girls yeah you know I took this role
because you know on the phone before I
ever read the script and it's very
secretive these things you know yeah you
can see much yeah yeah and you can't you
also don't know a lot when you're first
going into it and I said I am NOT
interested I'm not interested and they
then you know Zack Snyder explained to
me a little bit of who this character
was and he said she's a warrior queen
this is no damsel this is no you know
typical you're the female counterpart to
him she he said just read who comes it
you know you just your warrior queen I
went sword and a crown
hey my number but then I looked at the
comic book and in first scene you know
she's like they both her and Aquaman
both Mira and Aquaman save a town and
the town smokers running around saying
like you know who who is this who are
you are you aqua woman and she's like
whoa I'm not aqua woman I have my own
name it's Mira yes I'll take it so it's
great to see that she has the whole
water power hyperkinesis but she has
that whole thing going for her but she's
also a badass proactive strong don't
mess with me character who does her own
saving and I love that about her